today I am going to a really an event
that happened to me many years ago and I
wanted to give a very personal
perspective to help people in this place
an outside understand one element of
sexual violence against women when I was
14 I was raped as is common it was by
somebody who was known to me he had
offered to walk me home from a youth
event and in those days everybody walked
everywhere it was quite common to do
that
it was early evening it wasn't dark I
was waiting I'm imagining I'm guessing
jeans and a sweatshirt I knew my way
around where I lived I was very
comfortable and we did go a slightly
different way but I didn't think
anything of it he asked me he told me he
wanted to show me something in a wooded
area and at that point I must admit I
was alarmed I did have a warning bell
but I overruled that warning bell
because I knew him and therefore there
was a level of trust in place and to be
honest looking back at that point I
don't think I knew what Reap
was it was not something that was talked
about my mother never talked to me about
it I didn't hear other girls or other
women talking about it
it was mercifully quick and I remember
first of all feeling surprised then fear
then horror as I realized I quite simply
couldn't escape because obviously he was
stronger than me and there was no sense
even initially of any sexual desire from
him which I suppose looking back again I
find odd my senses were absolutely
numbed I'm thinking about it now 37
years later I remember I cannot remember
hearing anything when I replay it in my
mind now as somebody who's an ex
professional musician who is very very
auditory I find that quite telling I now
understand that your subconscious be not
your conscious be makes a decision on
your behalf as to how you should respond
whether you take flight whether you
fight or whether you freeze and I froze
I must be honest
afterwards I walked home alone I was
crying I was cold and I was shivering
and I now realize of course that was a
the shock response I didn't tell my
mother I didn't tell my father I didn't
tell my friends and I didn't tell the
police I bottled it all up inside me
I hoped briefly and appallingly that I
might be pregnant so that that would
force a situation to help me control it
and of course without support the
capacity and resources I had within me
to process it were very limited I was
very ashamed I was ashamed that I had
allowed this to happen to me and I had a
whole range of internal conversations
about I should have known why did I go
that way why did I walk home with him
why wasn't didn't I understand the
danger I deserved it because I was to
this I was to that I felt that I was
spoiled and impure and I really felt
revulsion towards myself
I of course been detached from the child
up to that I had been a novel written
reality at the age of 14 that was
probably the start of my sexual
awakening at that time remembering back
sex was something that men did to women
and perhaps this incident reinforced
that early belief I briefly sought fever
elsewhere and I know understand even a
brief period of hyper sexuality is about
trying to make sense of an incident and
reframe the most intimate of acts my
oldest friends with whom I'm still
friends must have sensed a change in me
but because I never told them they
didn't know of the cause and I allowed
myself to drift away from them for quite
a few years and indeed a foamer self
taking time off school and staying at
home on my own listening to music and
reading and so on I did have a boyfriend
later years of school and he was very
supportive when I told him about it but
I couldn't make sense of my response and
it is my response it gives weight to the
event
I carried that guilt anger fear sadness
and bitterness for years when I got
married 12 years later I felt I had a
duty to tell my husband I want attempt
to understand why there was a swaddled
care not of extreme emotion are the very
heart of me that I knew he could sense
but for many years I simply could not
see the words without crying I could not
see the words and it was only in my
mid-40s
I took some steps to go and get help
with it so it had a huge effect to me
and it fundamentally unfair to me
undermine my self-esteem my confidence
and my sense of self-worth despite this
I am i blessed in my life I've been
happily married for 25 years but if this
was the effect from one small albeit
significant event in my life stage how
must it be for these women who are
carrying this on a day-by-day basis and
I thought carefully should I speak about
this today and that almost in take a
breath what you are going to go and talk
about this was exactly the reason that
motive me motivated me to do it because
there is still a taboo about sharing
this kind of information and certainly
for people of my generation it is truly
shocking to be talking in public about
this sort of thing
and as somebody era marked earlier it
doesn't just affect the woman affects
the family as well and before my mother
died early of cancer I really wanted to
tell her but I couldn't bring myself to
I have a daughter and if something
happened to my daughter and she couldn't
share it with me I would be appalled and
so it was possibly currently but it was
an act of love that I made that I
protected my mother as an adult
of course you know no creeps not about
sex at all it's all about power and
control and it is a crime of violence
and ice
pick up on where the myths of rape are
perpetuated from a male perspective
surely you could have fought him off did
you scream loudly enough and the idea
that some men would suggest that woman's
giving subtle hints or as making it up
is outrageous these assumptions put the
woman at the heart of cause when she
should be at the heart of effect a rape
happens when a man makes a decision to
hurt someone he feels he can control
rapes happen because of the rapist not
because of the victim and we women in
our society have to stand up for each
other we have to be courageous we have
to call things out and see where things
are wrong we have to support and nurture
our sisters as we do with our sons like
many women of my age I have on occasion
encountered other aggressive actions
towards me both in business and in fact
in in politics but one thing I realize
now is that I'm not scared
and he was I'm not scared I'm not a
victim I'm a survivor thank the
Honorable they deeper what she has said
in the way in which she said it which
has left an indelible impression upon us
all